according to on YouTube insight
demographic information there is a 53
point 12 percent chance that you are a
teenage girl in some ways this confuses
me in others it doesn't I may not get a
lot of comments from people all the time
telling me that I am hot but the reason
I find this odd is because for the
entirety of my life the one demographic
that I have never been able to fully
understand is teenage girls I guess more
than anything it's just annoying not to
have girls watching me but because I
don't I don't know what to provide you
girls with it makes me feel like I
should start talking about fashion or
doing makeup awesome me you know I don't
what so what I decided to do TM is begin
my journey into the minds of teenage
girls and what do you do if you want to
understand the mind of a teenage girl
you give them a survey no fighters
yesterday I compiled a survey I sent it
out to the Internet via Twitter at the
day we're going to be looking at the
results from the teenage girls who took
this survey first off I asked them what
their favorite TV shows were five of the
girls thought that YouTube was a TV show
another five of these teenage girls
don't even know what a TV is 17 teenage
girls seem to think that this is a TV
show this is this is the internet right
and 11 teenage girls said that their
favorite TV show was my mum say hello to
your fans mum hello secondly I asked
them what their hobbies were a few
examples we have bird-watching stalking
youtubers burning myself with hair
straighteners chasing statues watching
me from the bushes outside my window
harassing people in banana costumes
wasting my time filling in pointless
surveys when I should be studying for my
a levels sorry looking after my cows
writing about different ways to pick
your nose and being constantly confused
by boys I guess it's nice to know that
the confusion is mutual next up is
relationships I ask these lovely ladies
what they look for in a partner seven of
these teenage girls so that they wanted
their partner to have a face one teenage
girl said that they wanted a heart and
19 teenage girls said that they wanted a
heartbeat one teenage girl here is
looking for cat ownership 25 girls said
that they were looking specifically for
me I asked them what their favorite
foods are here are some examples Z meter
Bulls with Z potatoes ammonium
bicarbonate
anything blue ramen ramen barely fluff
there is at least one person here who
doesn't even know what food is human
entrails human blood pizza human flesh
human meat yeah okay we're just gonna
stop here and finally I asked them in a
given day what are the top three things
that go through your head for me really
this is the most important question
because if I know what is going on in
their head then I know what to provide
them with a hundred and twenty two
teenage girls right me is one of the top
things that they think about on a daily
basis some of them think about my left
little toe some of them think about my
moles some of them think about me and
the thong some of them think about me in
their beds the top three things right
the teenage girls think about on a daily
basis why do I smell like pickles how
can I make that into an obscure Doctor
Who reference how much wood would a
woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck would
chuck wood
I wonder if I can fit in that dryer what
I okay right conclusions what I can
conclude from this is that I will never
fully understand what goes on in the
mind of a teenage girl ever but I can
gather from my evidence that it is
apparent they do think about me an awful
lot I wish I could understand my
audience
I wish Oh God mental breakdown on camera
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool Freddy yeah
you're a teenage girl oh yeah but I
understand you